the beauty is that it has affected these
companies not because it was a top-down
decision but the average person just saw
this finally enough of us started
talking about it and then the average
person decided to put their money use
their wallet elsewhere right and what
that does is it makes it so that you
actually have some power this is really
extraordinary stuff now updates on some
of how this has affected these
corporations this is from The Daily Mail
Bud Light is now cheaper than water at
some retailers after the 20 billion
dollar Dylan Mulvaney disaster as some
stores report 50 percent decline in
sales year on year after marketing
gimmick gone wrong so it actually
doesn't matter whether as Joe Rogan said
this was just like a throwaway thing
where they were like okay Dylan Mulvaney
put this up on social media we didn't
put much thought into it or it was a
real corporate decision actually we know
it was a real corporate decision because
we've played I think a couple times for
you guys some of the videos of the
executives saying why they were pushing
this right why they wanted a more
diverse beer drinking audience and that
they didn't want to be so focused on
Frat Boys they wanted it to be more
enlightened or something like that by
the way the two Executives in charge of
the campaign have been fired so it was
actually specific and targeted not just
a little throwaway thing
foreign
[Music]